together Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie
formed a blazing Hollywood supernova but
now that the ultimate celebrity couple
have split up we're about to find out
which half of the duo formerly known as
Brangelina shines the brightest alone
Brad Pitt versus Angelina Jolie who's
the bigger star round one Awards Jolie's
trophy case boasts three Golden Globe
statues for her work in 1997's George
Wallace 1998 gia and 2000 Girl
Interrupted the latter also earned her a
Best Supporting Actress Oscar and a SAG
Award Brad Pitt no award season slouch
of course he's got his own Oscar and a
BAFTA for his part as the producer of
the 2013 Best Picture winner 12 years a
slave a Golden Globe for his supporting
role in 1995 12 monkeys and an Emmy for
his work as an executive producer on the
2014 HBO drama the normal heart
advantage neither both need to build
secondary support beams on their
respective prized shelves just to hold
all their shiny bits so maybe the real
winners here are their contractors round
2 extracurriculars it's Angelina's
humanitarian accomplishments outside of
acting that really set her apart from
Brad in 2001 long before their
relationship even began she was named to
a goodwill ambassador position by the
United Nations after visiting with
Afghan refugees in Pakistan she remained
in that role until 2012 when she was
promoted to special envoy with a UN High
Commissioner for Refugees also in 2001
she began a conservation efforts in
Cambodia which would eventually give a
secondary citizenship it's also where
she adopted her son Maddox other
humanitarian awards include an order of
st. Michael and st. George from Queen
Elizabeth and a Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award from the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences to be
fair Pitt did participate in many of
Jolie's oversea efforts over the years
and his name is right there in a total
of the jolie-pitt foundation they
started together in 2006 notably Brad
Lloyd's to Make It Right foundation in
2007 and after Hurricane Katrina left
New Orleans Ninth Ward in ruins he
courted investors to rebuild the
neighborhood with sustainable materials
advantage Jolie's been seen with the
boots on foreign soil as often a tea
house with her heels on glitzy red
carpets welp its participation doesn't
count for nothing Jolie definitely
has the way to your name within the
international philanthropy community
round three paychecks it's basic math
Pitts makes an estimated 30 1.5 million
annually while Jolie is said to bring in
roughly half of that according to Forbes
even their first shared starring vehicle
mr. and mrs. Smith had a significant
rumored pay discrepancy with Pitt
allegedly pulling 20 million and Jolie
collecting just 10 million for equal
screen time though Jolie's has some
significant paydays of her own ranging
up to 20 million for 2010 salt cared was
rumored to make as much as 30 million
for 2001 Ocean's eleven his biggest
financial boon though comes by way of
his plan B entertainment production
company which has produced films like
World War Z or World War Z if you're an
American and the Big Short add a cool 60
million dollar Netflix deal to that and
the victory is clear advantage when Pitt
gets a spot in front of the cameras and
a seat of the production table its money
in the bank round for ticket sales Joe
Lee's most successful film to date is
Disney's Maleficent which earned a
whopping 758 point five million
worldwide Pitts biggest earner was World
War Z which took in 540 million across
the globe it spits only picture to cross
the 500 million threshold but Jolie's
got the three Kung Fu Panda movies to
add to a column in total Pitts movies
have made almost 7 billion worldwide
while Joe Lee's picks are closing in on
a respectable 6 billion interestingly
enough
Julie's reported opening box office
average is just a hair higher at around
68 million or pizzas around 67 million
another minor difference is the fact
that of their top 10 most successful
movies Jolie has three that featured her
as a singular central lead Maleficent
Lara Croft Tomb Raider and salt all Pitt
Scott - The Curious Case of Benjamin
Button and World War Z advantage Jolie
but it's a squeaker Jolie tends to take
on projects people are willing to track
out the theaters to see and she does it
with a touch more consistency than Pitt
what an awkward situation round 5 PR
skills Jolie is whip-smart about the
fame game and there's plenty of proof
consider the time when she penned her
own harrowing op-eds in The New York
Times about getting a double mastectomy
and then a hysterectomy after managing
to avoid the paparazzi long enough to
actually have these treatments
done and then there's the way she
started capitalizing on the tabloid
value of a private life like photos of a
newborn children or wedding dress to
turn that into easy money made for
charity Pitt meanwhile tends to keep a
lower profile with the media instead of
using it to his advantage advantage
Jolie by a mile round six sex appeal
both Jolie and Pitt earned a significant
amount of their initial fame based on
their devastatingly good looks
check out pit and Fight Club or is extra
toned chest and Troy how about Joe Lee's
bar scene in wanted it's a scientific
fact they are considered some of the
world's most attractive humans advantage
they're both hot and they both know it
but Pitt gets the advantage as a
two-time sexiest man alive round seven
the endorsements Jolie nabbed a massive
ten million ad deal to problem Bataan
which is why she always seems to have
one of the fashion houses bags in hand
Pitt meanwhile scored seven million to
make a laughably awful commercial for
Chanel number five and added another
three million to his stats for a
Cadillac ad that only ran in China
advantage Pitt might be the more
frequent flyer in the ad lane
but when Jolie does it she goes big the
tali it's really close Jolie's got some
serious mainstream muster thanks a
fascinating image overhaul she's no
longer that weird girl you made out with
her brother but instead that rare
celebrity who actually uses her fame for
good people can't seem to look away and
not just because of her unique beauty
she's smart strategic and makes it worth
the watch
that said Pitt's been mr. popularity for
ages it's not just that he has always
been chummy with some of Hollywood's
chillest a listers or even the fact that
his name's checked in a pop country song
okay so you're Brad Pitt that donum a
much Jolie might be able to run a room
by talking about important issues but
people will gravitate toward Pitt to
hear him read the phone book Pitt was
already fully established before he and
Joey started all the Brangelina see 11
years ago and that's what gives him the
win here he got here first it's as
simple as that
victory Brad so Angelina that's what
losing sounds thanks for watching if you
want to learn more about Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie's divorce check out our
friends at Nikki Swift the same team
behind looper makes videos for the Nikki
Swift Channel